well how do you know when to factor by
grouping well when you have four terms
that's when you want to test to see if
fashion by grouping is going to work for
you so the terms are separated by a
minus or plus so if you have four groups
that's when you want to look at the
factoring by grouping method and see if
that's again that's going to work so
we're going to group the first two terms
and we're going to group the last two
terms but subtraction is really like
adding the opposite so I'm going to
write that like that okay
since retractions I get any opposite I
group the first two group the last two
now what you're going to do is you're
going to factor out the greatest common
factor out of this group and out of this
group so here that's going to be x
squared here that's going to be three
and I'm going to do negative three so
that leaves us with two X minus one now
notice how we have in this group and in
this group a two X minus one so what
we're going to do is we're going to
factor out that two X minus one out of
this group and this group it's like
doing the distributive property
backwards so you have two X minus one
that we factor out of this group so that
leaves us with x squared and we factor
two X minus one out of this group we're
left with three now with factoring
sometimes you have to factor further if
this had been a four that's a difference
of two squares you can factor that
further by in this case it's a three
it's it's not a difference of two
squares so that's as far as we can go